this is Mullen Beck the brussels
district that's become infamous for its
links to at least four terror attacks in
just the last few years alone most
recently of course the attack in Paris
where it's believed three assailants
spent at least some time living here
we've come to this district to find out
why it seems to have such a problem with
extremism Malin Beck isn't small a
hundred thousand people live here many
with origins in Morocco or Algeria it's
a tight-knit community it's also poor
unemployment is a major problem crime
and drugs are an issue as she is happy
for the deputy mayor says the terrorism
label is unfair oh dear
foreign evil profess on the gonna see
the person la vía TLD is on fire in six
mati faith this visit of Frankenstein do
whatever comes it militant Sunni cons of
a Latin or the convention and actively
girl this was a reflection on what Jenny
before nor Pope Innocent so this is the
bar owned by the Abdul Salam brothers
one of those brothers blew themselves up
in the attack on Paris this is the
notice they pinned on the door it says
it's closed down because they suspected
that drugs were being sold from here and
consumed on the premises you knew other
salam or you met him yeah usually it's
here come here to eat with his friends
some nice guy is away from Islam because
the used to drink alcohol
Vaughn dodo dodo
we've just been speaking to a gentleman
who works at a community outreach center
here interest in he is telling us about
as well as the problems the poverty
unemployment amongst young people here
the order also told us that he's not at
all surprised that radical Islam has
taken grip here you actually spoke to
the security services and warned them
that you have concerns about some people
here but not in this case of Paris I'm
speed yeah but in the in the past you've
done it in the past in the past and
there I can't say because it's a bit of
frustration for me because my job say
listen do something and you said to me
yeah we know them but but okay we know
now we know where they are but it's keep
them in one place and let us just let
them dare
we're just following the place crowds
they got a line of vans here armed cops
up ahead and we're trying to find out
what's happened but it looks like this
is part of the continuing hunt for one
of the Paris bombing suspects it turns
out some involuntary
two key one being in the spotlight this
one young man did agree to speak to us
the next day his part in life
depressingly common here got in trouble
with the law when he was young
spent 10 years in prison and is now
jobless and angry lugosi sell a service
fall do exist it says Padilla Pass
Christian exists per se test idea you
can pop up the Moscow Circus from party
Christopher made the Pucci cottage
compound this groups this kind of
frustration group has nothing to do in
this country when you have someone who
comes to you to us at you know what I'm
doing here
look how are you treated like nothing
like dirt come to saya come to Iraq you
will get money you will get situation
you will get anything what maybe you're
going to be a general maybe gonna be a
minister come on this country is not
yours you go to Morocco is not yours
because even more of a tutu like a
swinger because you don't have the
accent you don't speaking the language
of the country leave and there is your
country there is you have a reason you
have this you have that you have
something and you have the religion
which religion violence killing people
that's religion it's very important that
the politics that we all the bedrooms
here we have to know that we have to be
concerned about the problem that our
children we have to treat them as
children to listen to them and give them
the chance and treat them like be
Belgium 100 percent
cool Muslim et al em and had a huge
killer a cool idea saladna no Kenneth
been to whom off to who Oh boohoo
even though what is the message from him
to young disaffected men who may be
becoming interested in kind of Salafist
radical Salafis ammonia hose illogical
toilet Alamo
Edea yet horrible Minden dilemma
material for Elie Samaha fatty layer who
do know Islam mean it differs oh maybe
they all are back this is a rally in the
main square around two to three thousand
people have come to show their
solidarity with the people of Paris but
probably more importantly to try to
remove themselves from a stigma of this
place and the kind of actions carried
out by the Abdul Salam brothers who were
involved in those Paris attacks and
whose family live in the apartment here
and you'll notice that they've lit
candles on their balcony life has rarely
been easy in London Beck the Terrorism
tag has made it even harder there are
lots of angry young men but there's also
a strong community trying to heal the
wound and restore a battered reputation
you